deux ans après la mort de zineb redouane
80 ans lors d'une manifestation de gilet
jaune
ils étaient plusieurs milliers ce samedi
à s'être rassemblés sur le vieux port
pour lui rendre hommage
aujourd'hui elle la famille de la
victime est toujours sans réponse et
c'est dans ce cadre que la fille de
zineb redouane a directement porté
plainte cette semaine contre l'ancien
ministre de l'intérieur christophe
castaner pour altercation et
soustraction de preuves
les proches de la défunte réclame
justice aujourd'hui oui effectivement à
la police et est coupable mais le
ministre de l'époque est tout aussi
coupable que la pole ici on demande à ce
que tous ses membres là soient
condamnées au tard le ministre que la
police ait autant que toutes les
personnes qui ont mis en place des des
fringues pour que l'un quatre semaines
ne soit pas mené jusqu'au bout un
rassemblement auquel se sont joints des
gilet jaune est des manifestants contre
la loi sécurité globale comme à paris et
dans d'autres villes du pays est les
participants ont tenu à exprimer leur
colère contre les violences policières
c'est vrai que depuis quelques temps on
voit à la télé des burress policière
même temps que gilet jaune ça fait plus
de deux ans qu'on avait subi des
violences policières et des violences
policières grave on a déjà comme perdues
des mains on a des borniers on a des
gens qui ont été roués de coups si
l'ambiance était quelque peu tendue la
présence des forces de l'ordre fut dans
l'ensemble plutôt discrète
plusieurs fumigènes et engins
pyrotechniques ont été utilisés par les
manifestants
mais l'ambiance bien loin des violents
heurts qui ont émaillé la mobilisation
parisienne